[Musique]
Stu session jeune groupe de rock
prometteur s'est produit au festival
food rock de manilon samedi 13 octobre
c'est l'un des si groupes programmés
pour la 2è édition du festival manikois
toute l'équipe c'est une équipe de
passionné et on a envie de monter un
grand festival rock aujourd'hui a il y a
deux grands festivals on va dire lefs
qui est très orienté métal extrême il y
a rock en scè qui est qui qui navigue
sur la pop le rock un peu de hard rock
mais nous ce qu'on a envie de faire
c'est c'est c'est du rock et c'est vrai
que moi j'ai coutume de dire c'est un
peu l'étiquette marketing du festival
c'est ça va du blues fondateur jusqu'au
métal
ravageur après stuff session au sonorité
funk rock le groupe Locom RT orienté
hard rock est monté sur la scène de
[Musique]
l'estaminet mais la tête d'affiche dans
ce t les food rock c'est hmé un groupe
de métal alternatif qui a sorti lundi 15
octobre un nouvel
album album est sorti avec la voix de
l'ancien chanteur donc Thomas euh
derrière on a fait quelques dates et
puis on a eu le feu vert de atom not
notre maison de disque pour faire donc
la réédition de l'album qui sort là ce
lundi 15 octobre euh donc on a sorti une
deè galette avec la première galette et
donc il y a trois titres enedy studio et
trois titres live le métal en général
est une musique comm une autre quand
quand tu vas dans les pays anglo-saxons
ou ou ailleurs en Europe en Scandinavie
et cetera le rock est le rock et le
métal sont des milieux comme les
autres défendre l'image du rock un
objectif que le festival food rock
espère atteindre au fil des ans le
public se montre déjà fidèle 200
amateurs de rock sont venus applaudir
les musiciens autant que lors de la
première
[Musique]
édition